MAKE NO MISTAKE, THE DEMOCRATS
IN CHARGE OF THE HOUSE, THIS
CHARADE IS NEVER, EVER GOING TO
STOP.
JOINING US NOW WITH MOORE'S
MINORITY WHIP CAUCUS CHAIRMAN
ANDY BIGGS.
GENTLEMEN, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
JOINING US.
CONGRESSMAN SCULLY'S COME WITH
THE PRESS CONFERENCE HOW THEY
WANT MORE EVIDENCE.
AREN'T THEY KIND OF DE FACTO TO
IMPEACH THE PRESIDENT WITHOUT
EVIDENCE?
AM I READING THIS RIGHT?
THEY ALREADY TOOK A BOAT, KNOW
THEY HAVE ENOUGH EVIDENCE TO
IMPEACH.
THIS SEEMS BACKWARDS.
>> WE SET THIS ALL ALONG, THERE
WAS NO CRIME.
IT WAS AN IMPEACHMENT IN SEARCH
OF A CRIME AND THEY NEVER FOUND
ONE.
ALL OF THEIR WITNESSES, STAR
WITNESSES SAID THERE WAS NO
CRIME, NO BRIBERY AND NOW YOU'VE
GOT PELOSI CARRYING OUT HER OWN
QUID PRO QUO.
SHE IS TRYING TO SAY COME I
WON'T GIVE YOU THE PAPERS UNLESS
YOU DO THIS.
AND IS THAT WHAT THEY WERE
ACCUSING PRESIDENT TRUMP OF?
JOE BIDEN DID QUID PRO QUO HE
BRAGGED ABOUT.
I WILL TAKE THE TAXPAYERS MONEY
IF YOU DON'T FIRE THE
PROSECUTOR.
BUT THEY IMPEACHED HIM FOR IT.
THIS IS BIZARRE.
AND LOOK, THERE IS NO FAITH.
IT'S DIMMICK IT IS TIME FOR HER
TO GIVE THIS UP AND FINALLY WORK
FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
WE CAN DO MORE ON DRUG PRICES.
WE CAN HAVE A SECURE BORDER AND
SO MANY OTHER THINGS, BUT THEY
ARE THE PARTY OF IMPEACHMENT.
THIS IS ALL THEY HAVE.
>> Dan: CONGRESSMEN BEFORE I
GO TO CONGRESSMAN BIGGS, IF IT
IS FASCINATING THEY ALLEGED QUID
PRO QUO WITH THE PRESIDENT AND
THE FIRST WITNESS SAID NEVER
HAPPEN GORDON SONDLAND AND YET
THE CHIEF EXECUTIVE OF THE
COUNTRY CONCERNED ABOUT
CORRUPTION IN FOREIGN AID.
HE SAID THAT MANY TIMES AND YET,
NOW WE HAVE NANCY PELOSI WITH
UNCONSTITUTIONAL USURPATION OF
THE SENATE POWERS AND WHERE IS
THE MEETING ON THIS?
CELEBRATING HOW WONDERFUL
NANCY PELOSI IS.
AM I READING THIS WRONG?
>> YOU ARE SPOT ON.
LOOK, THE MEDIA WHEN THEY WERE
KEPT OUT OF THE ROOM BY
ADAM SCHIFF, WHERE WAS THE MEDIA
THEY ARE SAYING WE WILL NOT LET
YOU IMPEACH IN SECRET BEHIND
CLOSED DOORS.
THIS IS NANCY PELOSI, LITERALLY
SAYING SHE HAS NO CASE.
SHE'S ALREADY LOST ONE DEMOCRAT
OVER THIS FIASCO LAST WEEK.
JEFF ANDREWS HAD ENOUGH ALREADY.
I WILL NOT BE A PART OF THIS
ANYMORE.
WHO KNOWS HOW MANY MORE SHE WILL
GET TO SWITCH OR BEAT NEXT YEAR
BECAUSE THE COUNTRY IS FED UP
WITH THIS THEATRICS, THIS DRAMA
BY SPEAKER PELOSI, NOW TRYING TO
TAKE OVER THE SENATE.
SHE HAS NO CASE IN THE HOUSE.
SHOULDN'T MOVED IMPEACHMENT IN
THE FIRST PLACE BUT THEY DID IT
ANYWAY PAIR THE COUNTRY SAYS
LOOK, FOCUS ON LOWER DRUG PRICES
AND CARE ABOUT THE WORKING
FAMILIES.
FORTUNATELY, PRESIDENT TRUMP
CARES ABOUT THOSE FAMILIES AND
DELIVERING A GREAT ECONOMY WITH
A LOT OF PEOPLE AND A LOT MORE
MONEY IN THEIR PAYCHECKS THIS
CHRISTMAS.
>> Dan: CONGRESSMAN BIGGS, I
HAVE TO BELIEVE THE DEMOCRATS AS
MUCH AS I DISAGREE WITH THEIR
RANCID POLITICAL IDEOLOGY, THEY
ARE NOT STUPID, THEY ARE NOT.
THEY ARE USUALLY TACTICALLY
EFFICIENT.
THEY HAVE TO KNOW THIS HAS BEEN
A SPECTACULAR FACE PLANT, PUBLIC
POLLING IS DOWN, INDEPENDENTS
MOVING IN THE OPPOSITE
DIRECTION, SWING STATE POLLS
DEVASTATING, MINORITY SUPPORT
FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP GOING UP.
I STOLE SOME NUMBER RAISING
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS ON THE DAY
OF IMPEACHMENT FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP!
ARE YOU SENSING ON THE HILL THAT
SOME OF THESE 31 DEMOCRATS AND
TRUMP DISTRICT'S ARE STARTING TO
SAY, WE HAVE A PROBLEM HERE AND
WE MAY WANT TO SLOW THIS DOWN.
IS THIS WHERE THIS IS COMING
FROM?
>> SOME ARE CONCERNED BY OTHERS
ARE STUCK IN THE MIDDLE WITH
NANCY PELOSI.
SO I THINK YOU'VE GOT SOME THAT
ARE MORE RATIONAL THAT ARE
SAYING, HEY, THIS IS A REAL
PROBLEM FOR US, BUT, YOU KNOW,
DAN WHAT YOU ARE SEEING IS A
REFLECTION OF AUTHORITARIAN
NATURE OF THE LEFT
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
SO NANCY PELOSI IS GOING TO GO
OUT THERE AND BASICALLY COMPEL
THE MEMBERS GO FOR AN
IMPEACHMENT THAT DOES NOT HAVE
POPULAR SUPPORT AND DOES NOT
COME AS YOU POINTED OUT, HAVE
EVIDENCE.
IF THEY GET THROUGH THIS AND IF
IT GETS OVER TO THE SENATE IT
NEEDS TO BE ACQUITTED WHICH WE
ALL KNOWS HE WILL BE.
THEY WILL DO IT AGAIN.
THAT IS THE AUTHORITARIAN NATURE
YOU SEE IN THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
THAT ACTUALLY BEATS DOWN ON THE
31 DEMOCRATS WITHIN THOSE SWING
DISTRICTS.
THEY ARE ALL IN TROUBLE.
>> Dan: CONGRESSMAN SCALISE IS
THAT AOC LEFT LEANING -- WINNING
TO THE PARTY?
DO THEY HAVE THIS MUCH POWER?
I WAS TALKING ABOUT BEFORE
CONGRESSMAN BIGS AND MY QUESTION
HERE IS SHE HAS TO KNOW THIS HAS
TO LEAD TO AN ELECTORAL
DISASTER.
THE REPUBLICAN TAKING OF THE
HOUSE, THE SENATE COMMITTEE
LANDSLIDE VICTORY FOR
DONALD TRUMP, THIS IS GOING TO
STAY IN HER LEGACY FOREVER.
I THOUGHT NANCY PELOSI WOULD BE
SMARTER THAN THIS.
YOU ARE IN A LEADERSHIP POSITION
BUT AGAIN, WHAT AM I MISSING?
SHE IS USUALLY TACTICALLY
SMARTER THAN THIS.
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, SHE USED TO
BE IN CONTROL OF THAT CAUCUS.
NOW WITH THIS NEW SOCIALIST
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, AOC AS YOU
WERE INDICATING, AOC IS DRIVING
THE TRAIN NOW.
IT'S HER PARTY.
IF YOU GO BACK TO THE
IMPEACHMENT INQUIRY, SHE WAS NOT
GOING TO DO AN IMPEACHMENT AND
WHEN WE CAN AOC TWEETED THAT THE
REAL CRIME IS THE DEMOCRAT
MAJORITY NOT IMPEACHING
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
LITERALLY, TWO DAYS LATER,
NANCY PELOSI SAID SHE WOULD
IMPEACH THE PRESIDENT.
AOC IS DRIVING THIS PARTY.
WHY SO MANY MODERATES HAVE NO
PLACE LEFT.
THERE ARE NO BLUE DOGS LEFT IN
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY VIRTUALLY
HERE AND SHE'S RUN THEM OFF
BECAUSE THEY ARE TIRED OF THE
SOCIALIST STYLE.
THAT'S ALL SHE'S GOT AND THEY
ARE CONTROLLING THINGS RIGHT
NOW.
>> I FORGOT ABOUT THAT.
>> Dan: CONGRESSMAN BIGS,
NOTHING THEY TOLD US ABOUT THIS
IMPEACHMENT WAS STREWN NO QUID
PRO QUO, FIRST-HAND WITNESSES
TOLD US THE EXACT OPPOSITE.
GORDON SONDLAND SAID THEY BEEN
CRYSTAL CLEAR NO QUIT PRO QUOTE
AND THEY DON'T DO EVIDENCE FROM
THE LEFT BUT EVERYTHING THEY
TOLD US ABOUT EXTREME NATURE TO
BE RUSHED, HE HAS SUCH A DANGER
TO NATIONAL SECURITY IS
NONSENSE.
SO THEY RAN A RATIONALE THEY
WANT TO SLOW DOWN.
I CAN COME A LITTLE BIT OF
DISCONNECT WITH THE MESSAGE.
>> ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
AND IT SHOWS THE DISARRAY.
I THINK NANCY PELOSI IS NORMALLY
STRATEGIC BUT SHE'S GETTING
PRESSURE FROM THE LEFT.
THEY ARE IN DISARRAY RIGHT NOW.
AND IT ACTUALLY IS UNDERMINING
THE VERY NATURE OF WHAT THEY
THINK THEY ARE GOING TO DO IN
THE FUTURE IN THE 2020 ELECTION.
SO IT REALLY HAS CONSEQUENCES
ARE ELECTORALLY, IT HAS
CONSEQUENCES CONSTITUTIONALLY
AND OF COURSE THE INSTITUTION
ITSELF.
SHE HAS MISREAD THIS THING
TERRIBLY.
I DON'T KNOW WHO IS ADVISING HER
RIGHT NOW, BUT SHE OUGHT TO FIRE